foreign
the program is beginning momentarily
[Music]
welcome to the academy Museum of motion
pictures
the people as a traditional caretakers
of the water and land on which we
program curate educate convene and
discuss
we honor and respect the tongva
ancestors and the tongva community today
which continue to nurture this land and
water through traditional practice
activism art and education
we also acknowledge their continued work
to safeguard cultural resources
my name is Sadi Navarro my pronouns are
she and they and I am the coordinator of
film programs here at the Museum
thank you for joining us in our David
Geffen Theater for the animated short
Film nominees panel presented as part of
our Oscar week programming
before we begin the panel public
programming for 2023 Oscar week is made
possible by the Ruderman Family
Foundation which promotes authentic
representation in the entertainment
industry and full inclusion of people
with disabilities throughout all sectors
of society
I would like to thank our ASL
interpreters who will be assisting today
their names are ajamu brown
Samantha Smith and Alexa Harris
now please help me in welcoming to the
stage senior vice president of member
relations Global Outreach and awards
Administration Tom oyer
all right hello everyone how are you
thank you for coming today I hope you
all enjoyed the uh those you saw the
animated shorts earlier today or this
afternoon either way I hope you enjoy
them I'm here representing the member
relations and awards team and I want to
just kind of you know we have our five
animated short Film nominees that today
and so I think the question comes up is
how do we get here how do we get these
five nominees so I'm going to give you a
little overview of the process First
Step films need to qualify so in order
to qualify for the animated short film
category there's three different methods
for qualification one is they can either
do a one-week qualifying release in
theaters second is we have a qualifying
Festival process by which Phil animated
short films that win specific juried
Awards add number of festivals qualify
or they win one of the medals at our
Student Academy Awards throughout that
process is how we have our eligible
films the second step of the process the
films need to submit they do their
submission process to submit the film
how it qualified and provide that to the
academy I need to give a special thank
you and shout out to Michael Benedict
Lauren McPhee and the others on the team
Who oversee the handle the submission
process and without them this category
would not be possible
next step in the process if you have the
voting process by which our members of
the short films and feature animation
Branch those members we can opt in and
participate in the voting process they
have to view a certain number of films
to be eligible in the first round they
do an initial round of voting to
determine a short list of 15 films 15
animated shorts and then from there
members of that same Branch the short
films that feature animation Branch then
vote again to determine the five
nominees that you have here today the
final winner of the entire Academy
membership then votes to determine the
final winner in all 23 categories and
those votes are done they're complete as
of yesterday and the results will be on
Sunday
I would like to give a special thank you
to all the members that spend their time
volunteer time to view these eligible
films and vote please know how much we
appreciate it every year and we will
continually keep asking you for your
help every year next step I would like
to introduce to you the short films and
feature animation Branch chair this year
she's in her fifth year as a governor
she's a two-time Academy Award nominated
producer and a wonderful partner to work
with all year round please welcome Bobby
Arnold
for the short people here
welcome welcome everybody today it's
great to see you all here and I just
want to say uh you know a big thank you
on behalf of the three uh short films
and feature animation Branch Governors
myself and John Bloom and Marlon West we
are just so glad to have you here in
this uh this event be having this event
at our beautiful beautiful Museum uh and
thank you a special thank you to all the
uh Academy and Museum staff for helping
make this possible today we really
appreciate them
um I know you're excited about the
program so let's get going I'm excited
to introduce to you our moderator this
afternoon Glenn Keane is an
oscar-winning short filmmaker and
legendary character animator for 38
years he worked at the Walt Disney
feature animation where he designed and
animated some of our most beloved
characters in The Little Mermaid Beauty
and the Beast Aladdin Pocahontas Tarzan
entangled
in 2007 he received the Windsor McKay
award from asifa for his lifetime
contribution to the field of animation
and was named a Disney Legend in 2013.
episode
after Disney Glenn founded Glen Keane
Productions as a way to further his
exploration of Animation design and film
he has since collaborated with Partners
such as Google Spotlight Stories
and the Paris ballet
keene's collaboration with John Williams
and the late Kobe Bryant on deer
basketball received the 2018 Academy
Award for best animated short film
Glenn's most recent film over the moon
created in partnership with pearl studio
and Netflix was nominated for an Academy
Award in 2021 for best animated feature
film
without further Ado please welcome my
dear friend and colleague of 25 years
Glenn Keane
[Applause]
thank you Bonnie
um you know it's being back here is uh
I was here in 1975
but it wasn't the academy it was May
Company
and my wife worked in the wig department
there
which I think is a little bit ironic
when I think about the characters that
I've animated it's like
Pocahontas with her hair and the Beast
is so furry and Tarzan was dreadlocks
and then finally Rapunzel it's like I'm
making up for the lack of something in
my life I'm not sure what that is
but I'm really looking forward to
chatting with these filmmakers so unique
I don't know that there's ever been such
a divorce diverse array of
of styles and messages and it's really
really a very rich rich year
so before we bring out the panelists I'd
like to introduce I'd like to welcome
our ASL interpreters uh for them to come
out and take their seats
and then what I'll do is go ahead and
start to bring out the panelists
um from alphabetical order
seating seating down so we'll start with
an ostrich told me the world is fake and
I think I believe it with Lachlan
Pendragon
[Applause]
then my year of dicks Sarah gunas
daughter I'm I'm sorry Sarah if I did
not pronounce it properly and Pamela
ribbon
[Applause]
and then
for ice merchants
Joel Gonzalez and Bruno quitano
[Applause]
the flying sailor Amanda forbus and
Wendy tilby
and then the boy the mole The Fox and
the horse
Charlie magazine and Matthew Freud
[Applause]
so I guess we'll just get started
okay bye Mike
wow how exciting
film is done I mean it's quite quite an
accomplishment just to finish a film
much less to have it nominated for best
animated short
um
I know
how difficult it can be to actually get
something produced and presented to the
world the way you have and I just want
to congratulate each one of you for
accomplishing
something truly remarkable
particularly in this this time of covid
and all of that adding more weight on
already creatively burdened shelters
um but I I'd like to go around and uh
just ask
um questions for each one of you how how
did the team get together
um each of these little groups of teams
and
poor Lachlan I guess nobody wanted to
work with you huh
we'll get to that find out why
so
Matt
and Charlie
am I going in the right order here I'm
I'm hoping that I am or am I supposed to
go with
it's your choice
okay
yeah yeah so tell us tell us about
your team that I mean it's a very very
much a one-man show in many ways but I
know that there are other folks that are
your uh right-hand people uh yeah I yeah
I came to this as like a research
project so I had two supervisors that
I'd worked with before and so like for
my undergraduate degree so there was
already that kind of trust there where
we could kind of hit the ground running
um and so they were kind of the
collaborators and would meet a weekly
and sort of discuss ideas and uh yeah
that would help Elevate things to the
next step and that was sort of the team
the team that was there the whole way
for the project yeah
and so how long how long did you guys
work together
um so this project it was three years
wow yeah thank you congratulations wow
so Sarah and Pamela well so I wrote a I
wrote a lot of notes to Boys in high
school and I kept all the first drafts
so that's where this begins
um so three years that's good but this
is 30 something but so no and then um
I'd published them in a memoir and uh FX
had
approached me about doing something in
an animated space that was more
independent and personal and they
thought this might be a good fit to talk
about a young woman's fantasies and play
in the genres of animation and I was so
excited about that and once the script
was greenlit I always sent a few places
that might we might be able to afford
and as soon as I saw SATA I I fell in
love with the work she had been
recommended to FX by Jeanette Janine who
ended up becoming our producer on this
film and so we all met on a zoom one day
we were making this thing together
sorry
yeah and since we when we started
working together me Pam and Jeanette
we've spent four months in
pre-production 10 months with artists
and then four months finishing up
wonderful yeah what bold courage to make
this film I
yeah congratulations like a different
question
thank you
and uh so Joel and Bruno
how about you how did you find that
connection
yeah so uh very much like locks on my
luck on my film was also started as a
graduation film from Royal College of
Arts uh what we did I kept working on it
after graduating and that was when I was
able to find amazing people like Bruno
or alanunu and as a team in the film
very luckily for us got funded and we
went through with it so it was also a
very small team for example an animation
team was just me and Alo Nunu and we
worked through roughly two years with
some pauses in the middle because we're
also taking some commissions on the side
but I'll say the entire production would
be like roughly two years I think
and and Bruno have were you involved in
producing before
this film
um yes um I'm also a filmmaker so I met
you because of Allah in a festival where
he usually meets all the great animation
people and uh we had it off immediately
um and then just a few months later Juan
was trying to get his school film
in a way produced and we told them about
call animation which is our production
cooperative and he join us and we
started working together ever since and
we've been drone also besides this film
in those two years he also did other
films and some commission work so we
just try to help each other out as we go
along but the person responsible is
sitting right there at Sala nunu she's a
great animator she's the co-animator of
the project she animated about half of
the project as well fantastic
[Applause]
thank you
and Amanda and Wendy oh there you are
yeah
so how about you how did you two connect
uh Amanda and I've been working together
almost 30 years actually and we've known
each other almost 40 years wow so we go
way back we met at art school in
Vancouver British Columbia and um
we immediately I think we recognized
that we had a sympathy with each other
we had a similar
likes and tastes in film we had similar
sense of humor we just got along and
um
about well 10 years later I was starting
a film called when the day breaks at the
national film board in Montreal Amanda
came to work with me on it and we've
worked together ever since
oh
and what the flying sailor uh was
produced by the national film board
were to whom we're extremely grateful
and um
uh it took about three years to make
okay and earlier you were saying we're
not animators but yeah I did say well
real animators I said yeah no we were
talking about but she did a real
animated film we did make a real
animated film and uh um we were talking
about how Canada is a
um a very rich animation country and
that has a lot to do with the nfb but
that
there is also a school called Sheridan
which is in Ontario
um where people learn how to really
animate properly and and I think a lot
of the people you've worked with come
from there because they're such great
animators and we went to Art School
which is a bit
flakier in that department yeah yeah the
art school I went to was flaky too was
it yeah how did you learn to animate
yeah I I actually have not yet I'm still
working at it yeah you're a little rusty
so
Matthew and Charlie
so I think we're we're probably uh
unusual for lots of reasons but
um unusual here in that you know four
years ago
um
when Charlie brought a book out
um we've been friends for 30
years and and I guess what happens when
a book is successful is you get a lot of
incoming
calls through agents and through
production companies whatever saying and
the questions are the film rights
available and and we didn't really
understand the question
um but but there were enough of these
calls that that we we thought will it
would be you know fun or interesting or
or consistent with a project that had
tried to get these
characters and these messages out to as
many people as possible and so we
thought well how hard could it be to you
know make an animated film
and did you just really say that
there's a there's a line in the in the
book and the film which is what's the
bravest thing you've ever said and the
horse's help and and I think actually
the bravest thing that Stephanie I ever
said was oh let's make an animated film
um
but of all the people who'd who sort of
appeared from The Ether Cara speller who
was our amazing producer
um
was was the one who asked
um the best questions
uh and so we we decided that we'd you
know create a a gang of Musketeers and
which just grew and grew and grew to
about what 120 different animators in
and because it was during covert it was
it was
um they were scattered across across the
Earth and Charlie and the team Peter
Banyan who who came on as Charlie's
co-director uh John Croaker came across
as a as a co-writer
um and uh and then we had some grown-ups
in Bad Robot with Hannah and JJ
um who were always on the end of of the
phone when we needed it helps but so so
it was a I mean it was about two and a
half years I guess of
uh of production but but learning
learning learning learning all the way
well you went to art school she said I
didn't even do that
and and I I just so I made a book by
accident
um there were drawings I was doing for
friends that went on Instagram and then
kind of
came together somehow
um and then yeah so
I'm sitting here still in shock that we
did it and still grateful that Carlos
Bella came with us and helped us with it
um it was very difficult we did I think
four hours of student calls a day for
two years and I'm not easy I'm I'm the
patients are the people because I'm not
an animator
um I just draw so I had to do work with
the animators a lot of drawing over
their drawings and being I felt a bit
like a grumpy school teacher marking
kids work
um but they were wonderful and I'm
really grateful to them always
yeah so that's how it happened
kind of accidentally I think
it's amazing I mean for each each little
team here has created something that
would not have been possible without one
or the other it would have been
different
there's a uniqueness to what you've
created and
when when I'm watching the film and
anything that I'm working on I always
feel like there's a white hot Center
that I'm always drawn to like
what is that moment that the Angels Sing
when you're watching the film
and I felt that
with each each of your films
um it's not a wonder that they are each
nominated because they each have those
moments that stick with you and they hit
you
and they hit you hard and long after you
reflect on it
um
so I mean Lachlan I when I think of
of yours for me I'll tell you what I
think and you can tell me yeah that's so
wrong is not at all but for me it's when
you're very appealing identifiable guy
that he everybody's just like oh gosh
the poor guy
you made him relatable but when he falls
into that bin of face parts
to me that was like
it all came together at that moment and
you it was it was about identity and who
am I and all the questions fit together
at that point that was how it was for me
but
what was it for you
yeah definitely that character was the
sort of the following that character
through the film and he's sort of in
this place where he's stuck and doesn't
know where his life's going doesn't know
who he is
um and so yeah he's trying to search for
that and then at the same time realizing
that his world is stop-motion and then
that's a great sort of uh yeah lens to
view it through and I think that is a
really powerful moment where he's sort
of crumbling literally um as the Lansing
to a tray of his own faces this is the
puppet brought along with me today
[Music]
yeah don't sit on him please
and
so um
so Sarah and Pamela what
for you
let me just give you my opinion there
was
at the end
of
so many awkward moments and such
squirming like oh gosh
why can't she see
who she is why does she have to put her
you know value in what somebody else
says
and at that moment when the guy who
everybody through the whole film is
seeing can't you see the guy in front of
you values you at that moment where he
becomes vulnerable literally naked
um it all just came together in
sweetness and authenticity and it was
like that was the angel singing moment
for me
um and how how was it for you was were
there other moments like that
I think you should start
I think that was also my favorite part
of the story and when I read it and
I thought it was so smart uh how Pam led
us up to this moment
um I think she did it in a way that the
we don't necessarily see it coming and
that's why it's so sweet and I love the
fact that she's been
thinking so much about
sex and physical relation with other
people
and not really making a distinction
between that and feelings or I don't
know and then
in the end it isn't about
their bodies it's like she's putting the
clothes on they're not taking clothes
off and there's something just so really
beautiful about that
so it's it's it's
up here you know thank you yeah there's
no base for where they reach at the end
together you know I'm always surprised
when people think assume that she's
losing her virginity under there it
would have never occurred to me
um
thank you but for it's a different one
for me because it has more to do with
the power of Animation but I had a lot
of imaginary friends growing up I don't
know if you can tell and uh the moment
in the
in the janitor closet when he says he is
not me you or me regretemo and run and
uh there's something about that every
time where it's like
that's what you hope
could have happened or that could be
heard you know what I mean like that was
seeing she the way they did it the way
the team did it you could I that is what
it felt like and and I don't think I get
to see that a lot the angels I felt them
then I was like
that's it that's what I would want to
tell everyone you know
it's such a cool thing when you're
working on something creatively and you
don't even know that
kind of that Holy Ground you're walking
on and suddenly
you realize I am in the center of it
right now and it's it's just kind of
tells us how
creativity is
is really searching for something inside
of us that's coming out and by doing it
we discover it uh really really
wonderful thank you so and Bruno I mean
you're you're filmed to me
it was
wild and crazy as each one of the film
in their own right was
um
but the thing that really stuck in my
head the first time seeing it was that
third cup in the cupboard
um like
what's the third cup and why is it why
are they looking at it and then
realizing where's the mom and I'm kind
of slow I picked that up eventually
but that moment of holding the cup boy
looking at that
just
just valuing it
um that to me just really spoke of need
the need of that other person
perhaps it was something else that spoke
to you yep so in my process for my films
I normally always starts with an image
that I don't know exactly why I thought
of it for example in this case it was
that any house attached to a tall cliff
it's one of those images that you have
sometimes when you're just about to fall
asleep and you're like in this amazing
place but then you think about it and it
the image disappears completely it's
very frustrating so I like to pick those
scenarios as starting points and then
using them as metaphors to talk about
things that concern me and that's
touched me so I knew that this film was
going to be a film about loss it was a
topic that I wanted to cover and it's
interesting because a lot of the objects
and nuances of the film and the
narrative are something that I find
along the way because my pre-production
is a lot about imagining that house I
start to write a lot about it I started
to draw the house from any angles the
inside I start to compose this film
soundtrack and whenever all of these
working together in the pre-production
more concise ideas of objects or things
that could happen on the story starts to
appear so both the the heads and the
mugs were something that I started to
imagine the more that I was living
inside of the of that house virtually
that's the only way I couldn't do it and
um but but yeah it's primarily a film
about loss and the the mug represents
the demand as you know as the ads also
represents their daily life and how you
know the routine that those small
rituals that they did every day like
those silly jokes in a way uh each day
by day grew their Foundation of their
you know
um relationship human relationship
stronger every day just by living their
lives and being close to the close ones
through the whole film I'm my stomach is
tense and tight and everything was
precarious I wrote precarious down when
I was watching it it just tension and
yeah I mean just by visually staging it
that way is remarkable thank you so much
Bruno
um well it was wrong said it really well
uh I will not add to that I will just
say that when Jerome first introduced
the film
um I I had seen his two previous films
and I immediately told him well this
film is very different from your
previous two films it's a lot more
heartwarming even though it's about loss
it's uh it's about people and
connections and and that uh in a way
um I related a lot to it and and then
kovit started this was all met covet
when we were we were producing the film
and even though film is about law since
in a way it's very sad it was something
that was bringing us great joy to be
able to do every day we would get new
shots coming in either from Juan either
from our and these were the highlights
of a very weird time and nobody knew
what was going on but this film kept us
as a team and I was in Lisbon's Rome was
in Porto Allah was in France and we were
all separate but in a way we held each
other together so that that felt really
good it was it was like a little Safe
Harbor for everyone it was it was nice
it was a good process great way to put
it
so
this idea that the flying sailor
um
to laugh at every one of these because
they're so unexpected and fresh and
it's what animation should do to you it
should just make you shake your head and
go
oh
and for me this
um the flying sailor was
there was this moment
where you set it up
with
cartoony
kind of old-time jaunty music and
everything even the the boat every I was
like okay what kind of film are we in
and then the dynamite
um there's a fuse and then here comes a
sailor and it really felt old time and
everything I've I felt like is this
where it's going to go but that setup
and suddenly the violence and the
aftermath
um it was in
it was those three moments of
the fuse being let the jaunte Sailor
something something really unexpected is
coming and then you delivered this
um and it was
violence
um and
are you emotionally I was really just
hit with something like I don't know
that I've ever been hit with anything
quite as like what in the world happened
there I mean
the Angels were shouting they weren't
singing necessarily right there but uh
but then yeah we I can keep going but
what what about you how did you feel
well that uh
we considered for a while just how
different to make that prologue from the
the body of the film because we really
considered the film to really start at
the point of the explosion but um
we ended up going with that cartoony
style at the beginning
partly because it's it's suggested just
boxes of TNT what are you going to do
with that you're gonna you think Wiley
Coyote right away and uh but but the
main reason we did it was to uh that in
a sense it it is like the tone of life
as you go about your expected routines
and all the things that you have lined
up during the day and you know what's
going to happen it's all going to be
fine and then
we all end up with this explosive moment
in our life whatever it looks like it
could be a car accident or a piece of
bad news or a diagnosis there's so many
things and there's that clear marker
where life was one way yesterday and it
is entirely different today and so that
was um
that was the reason for doing that
um but in terms of the uh the angel
singing moment it's I'm glad you brought
that up because
um uh we were just talking about it the
other day that essentially every time we
make a film it's it's chasing that
Transcendent moment there there's that
moment that
you may not even have a film formed
around it yet but there's just perhaps a
single image that grabs you and hangs on
to you for years and for us it was um
the naked sailor in the sky and uh we I
I you know obviously The Originals the
the story of the actual story of the the
flying sailor it suggests itself and we
love the fact that it was both uh it's
I'm sorry to say it but it was funny
that his clothes came off clothes do
come off in explosions and leave and you
did it so slowly it was it was awesome
um but uh we love the vulnerability and
the little bit of humor in the context
of this horrendous event it just loved
the the mix of these uh contrasts the
beautiful and the terrible and the funny
and the sad and the poignant and the
ridiculous and so um
that Central image of the Sailor was
very important to us and then also to
imagine that flailing in the sky if you
slow it down enough will begin to look
intentional or balletic or possibly
beautiful and again we like this kind of
awkward middle-aged man doing these kind
of extreme poses in in the sky
and another Guiding Light for us was
there's a wonderful Canadian painter
named Betty Goodwin who did these um
absolutely beautiful paintings of bodies
of human bodies and they were never
identifiable as individuals they're
mostly shapes and they would look like
they were in water or lying on the
ground and and again they were really
beautiful and yet they were also
disturbing there was something terrible
about them
and so that those two things that the
thought of the sailor in the sky and
these Betty Goodwin paintings sort of
hung in our minds because we we hung
onto the idea for about
17 years before we did it so we had that
that was our nugget that was our angels
singing
same thing I think Amanda said it all
there but I'll add one thing was that
the um
as she mentioned the uh everything in
the prologue was just getting us to the
moment of explosion which is for us
where the film begins because we wanted
to take
what would have been a few seconds in
the air and we we expanded it into a few
minutes but we were interested in what
this trip was like for the Sailor as a
very subjective visceral experience
and it it amounts to a near-death
experience and that's what interested us
and
for me like I think the the moment when
the sailor he he loses his sense of his
physical self I mean he has his memories
he has his
uh his flailing balletic flailing
motions become
um it transitions into flying and that
kind of here's a moment of the fun of
flying before what we wanted to suggest
was his body his physical self
is disappearing it's becoming seamless
with the universe
and um there's a moment when he go when
it becomes outer space and it's the
white light and people really do report
white lights and exactly what I'm
talking about that loss of physical
self and um
for me that's the moment of
this kind of life is profound his life
is profound to him but it's also you
become one with the universe it's kind
of insignificant in the grand scheme of
things and that's what we wanted to
suggest with these becoming an atom
becoming a particle becoming
um nothing and um we didn't want it to
be horrible or depressing we wanted it
to be comforting not everybody might
find it that way but
um that was one of our thoughts
so cool hearing these
uh
so
Charlie and Matthew uh how about for you
guys
um for me
I can I'll just throw out my my thought
but there's a moment
your film to me has always been about
animating quiet I mean in somebody I've
never seen quiet animated
until this movie
um
and it there's this wonderful moment
where
um
the mall asked the boy what do you want
to be when you grow up
and
and it comes right at the end of just
the pan a beautiful pan of quiet snow
and it's so
gentle and that whole setup is preparing
you for that question and his answer
kind
I don't know how you could deliver that
in such a
in a more powerful way than the setup of
that and to me that was like okay I I
get this film now that was the angel
singing for me
thank you
um that's lovely uh well for me I used
to lie in bed when I was making the book
you know I'd see the film ceiling in a
really vague way and uh and um the bit
that I mentioned most was um well I was
at a I was signing some books and I was
really tired at the end of the day and a
boy came up to me he's at 18 and he just
said um I just want to he was awkward
and just said I just wanted to say thank
you and I said that's okay you know and
he said I just decided to stay
and I said I didn't really I said stay
as in the shop and I couldn't get it and
I said he had his eyes were full and I
looked him and he had the Page open
where the horse says what's the boys
asked what the bravest thing I've ever
said was
and he said can you just write your name
on this page
because I decided I'm here now and I
didn't go
and um so I started crying we both I
stared at him and I said well done
and I'm glad you did what you did and
Brave you and then he we had her get you
and then he left and I always imagined
how how that might look on my ceiling if
that was gonna be animated and filmed
and and I remember with you know we're
on the single car and everyone and I
remember seeing we finally got this bit
where the the horse pauses and the voice
says what's the bravest thing you've
ever said and
and there's a pause you know and and I
remember seeing that for the first time
that was my to answer your question that
was my angel my side because we had
music there and
it was kind of how I hoped
it would be and I I hoped when I saw it
that if that boy were to sit in this
form he'd have the same responses if he
hadn't read the book as he would do this
and that would always be my dream that
maybe someone out there who saw it would
choose to stay
um yeah as a writer what you just said
is got to be the goal that
that wasn't the character says something
it they've arrived at it because it
comes from inside them that it's real
and true
I love the way you put it Charlie how
about you Matthew
that there's a whispering angel
moment for me in the film with it I
think
one of the reasons why we decided to do
it
um in rather than sort of outside of
you know the book when it was coming
together was it was a bit like Charlie's
hair it was sort of relentlessly
incoherent
um and and the the Publishers and and
lots of people who well it said you know
they're like there's no story here it's
you know like you've got to have a story
in a book and Charlie went
no you don't
um and and it was a reasonable battle to
to to get this book
um you know through the various stages
of publisher approval with without
having a conventional narrative and and
so because we wanted to make a very
faithful version of them
certainly the spirit of the book and the
purpose of the book
um
that we didn't want to have to have
Jeopardy you know the sort of
conventional ingredients of of of a
story and it was actually my annoyingly
clever brother-in-law Richard Curtis who
who said that the boy is lost
and so there's that one moment at the
beginning of the film right literally
right at the beginning and he says what
are you doing here he says I'm lost and
that for me is the whispering Angel
because it actually allows you to track
the rest of the film and and and go from
you know scene to scene which isn't
conventionally
an unfolding story but you have a sense
of why they're there or what or what the
journey is
um to your Whispering angel
and just as a comment for the animation
of that was
you knew that he was lost just by that
acting that was was so clear and then
the the comment of being lost
just resonated true you know I love that
you said that I mean it's the animators
are so great and we're trying to embody
vulnerability fragility almost like you
wanted to hold him if you saw him you
know and there's a looseness in his
physicality yeah definitely
she tried to do
I mean I say essentially it's me I mean
I've always felt pretty lost you know
and um generally speaking sorry you know
the characters are more about you know
how we feel inside and I think generally
speaking I we all feel lost at least
some of the time
don't we
no Charlie what's going on I'm alone in
this okay I am the freak
to be vulnerable I mean
but I think that vulnerability brings
connection and I think I I was brought
up as a sort of English male to sort of
try to impress to get connection and
actually the thing that really tells you
is when you die to say something
you know then you all these situations
everyone hits a vulnerable moment and
that's that's when they connect you know
yeah
sorry
no it's wonderful
I wanted to ask talk about animation
um
that's this is what we do but it's
interesting that we're really not
talking so much about the technique of
Animation we're talking about why we do
it and
yeah the thing that drives us but on
my year of dicks I I was
amazed at the way you the way it was
animated you embraced live action
unabashedly
not even worrying about just how
carefully every line was done there you
just went with
performance and and so I I'd like you to
talk just a little bit about the acting
the life the actors that you used and
the choice to do that style was was
really remarkable
well I think the
where it be begins really is
um Pam was playing with this idea of
movie genres for his chapter
and when I read this and I thought oh I
get to do this I I get to bring a group
of my favorite artists and we all get to
have all of our own amazing art within
one project that was the most exciting
for me
there were seven animators on this
outside of myself
and um
I want it all all amazing animation
artists and filmmakers in their own
right Independent Artists
and I wanted them to bring their
aesthetic and their
sense of art to each chapter but then I
thought
I just want the Baseline to be very
natural so that
when we go away from that and allow the
animation to take flight like that's
that's where the Poetry happens
and I was thinking since they're all
already Lending
ham their own way of drawing
I wasn't concerned about that coming
through in the natural way of moving Pam
around and all of them
in that in that foundation of the
animation
so I was like yeah we're like
it's not a very big crew and we're just
all gonna be part of this little Pam
like we're all
lending her some sensibility of
ourselves
and I think also maybe a little part of
it was that um I had never tackled
anything this big
and very much used to working within the
live action production doing animation
within live action Productions
so I got really
what I've been doing for many years is
kind of developing this way of
shooting myself or my husband for
references as a foundation
and then
the design of the people or the
characters I'm working with are always
or usually based on real people or
actors
and when you have
the references is so much easier to draw
the character very much looking like the
real person and not a character
caricature of a person but you can just
it feels like a real person and not some
character that is made up I don't know
if it makes sense well I I really
understand that because yeah you are
really going into something that's very
very intimate and personal and human and
the style if it had been when I think
about it now if it had been a different
style
I think it would have been much more
difficult to communicate your ending
certainly
um
I think traditionally when you would do
a more traditional maybe like a
King of the Hill or whatever she becomes
the butt of the joke very very easily
and and the way that that Sada does this
with character and performance capture
you cannot pretend that's not a person
you can't laugh at her you're totally
going through that story with her and
her point of view
yeah
and then I think also part of it was
also uh
I was like oh I'm tackling this 25
minutes it feels like a lot of animation
but I had a really good team and I was
just like
I'm gonna
get an ulcer if I start worrying about
line and stuff like I was just like
details I'm just gonna throw them out
the window like
as long as we see the actors and the
characters
then it's then it's them it's then it's
fine it's all about the performance and
it makes them look
they make them look as uncomfortable as
it feels you know like sometimes Pam
turns her head and I'm like that's not
my nose but like that's how it probably
felt my nose looked like when I turned
to that boy at that moment and so it
really I think is adding to the squirmy
and that anyway yeah yeah squirminess
and also wonderful quality to get and
also because it's about Pam when she was
15.
and she had all these wonderful home
videos from that time which wasn't
common back in 1991 but she like she was
shooting herself on a VHS tape and I was
like oh this is talking to the youth
today I was just doing this all the time
wow
um
so and I was just like it's perfect to
just have Pam be Pam and I had she was
right there and we could just shoot her
face as much as we wanted it
So yeah thank you
in contrast
to your style
your style is an entirely different
thing and they they both reflect so much
about the story can you talk about your
animation style and design that fit into
the film and story you were trying to
tell of course I would say like
aesthetically my film is very much
inspired by the way I always like to
illustrate on my graphic book or
everything and the looking back I think
there's a logical reason why I like
specific aspects of what I tend to
incorporate in my films for example for
a long time I consider going to
architecture I was very drawn into
drawing Landscapes buildings way before
starting to draw characters so I think a
lot of my leftover perspective that I
try to incorporate in the film comes
from that as well
when I start to draw when I was uh
earlier way back in the days I was
always very interested in Shadows and
making things pop up more
three-dimensionally from initially from
vapor and then to the screen so I do
that in the film I was always very
interested in limited color palettes as
well so my challenge as a director I
feel is always trying to find a way of
incorporating you know things that uh
please me aesthetically but also making
it work conceptually with the film in a
way that's both innates each other so I
think that my love architecture
benefited the film into creating that
you know vertigo effect that I think
it's important to establish since the
beginning
as I believe that the Shadows may help
creating a more dramatic like tone to
the film and I also in terms of the
color palettes I I not only enjoy the
colors and I spend a lot of time like
although they are only like four or five
colors I spend a lot of days like trying
to get exactly the specific tone of each
one but to this score it was a way of
for me contrasting the warmer colors and
more Humane colors of both characters
and the house contrasting with the more
Arch colors of the outside and the
environments rough environment they live
in so yeah it's always a challenge for
me trying to combine those two and in
terms of the technique the film
initially I I conceived it to be fully
animated on paper
uh what happened is so we have a very
limited animation team it was just me
and alanunu and she was living in France
by that time
so MIA Bruno started to talk about it
and logistically speaking would be a
nightmare to ship like uh Pages back and
forth like each country so instead I'm
focusing on focus on trying to find a
way uh in Photoshop to simulate that's
more organic aspect that I was looking
for in the film so the film is actually
fully digital digital animation and also
very important again like it was a very
small team just mianala but the fact
that I was able to work with her you
know she's a much more experienced
animator than I am and because it was
just two animators I had to step up my
game otherwise you notice which shots
are animated and what she did so
actually working with her was not only
amazing because it benefited the film
but having to divide this like half half
obligated me to become a better animator
and director so I'm very thankful to
have that chance of working with her
you bring up something that I think I'm
trying to live out in my own life which
is what I call reverse mentorship where
you bring people that are better than
you at something around you and you
learn from them and often they're just
like really young and right out of
school and they may not even know how
good they are but those are the ones you
want to be surrounding yourself with
Bruno uh on the production side
um like Chrome was saying originally we
thought about doing this in paper and
the complications of it all we
immediately took a step back and with
kovid it would be 100 times more
complicated to ship things and if shots
were lost a lot of problems but we
established a really nice pipeline in
things went really well we had
practically no problems in this
production we took our time as well it
was amazing but one of the things I
would like to point out is the fact that
we've done loads of short films at Cola
but you know every director has his own
way of working especially when they're
working with teams that they're already
used to working with and in this case
which one he has a very distinct style
of starting an animation and
establishing a pipeline when it first
starts he goes back and forth between
the drawing table and the piano and this
is something that never happens for me
as a filmmaker I have a hard time
understanding the music when I'm
establishing the world
he does that naturally and immediately
there is no separation between what we
hear in the film and what we see in the
film and for me and for the rest of the
team that's also a very good way to
understand what he wants to do because
the music conveys such emotion that you
immediately understands what he wants to
set out to do on that shot or on that
sequence of shots and and that was as
well groundbreaking even though some of
us have worked on loads of films and
various Productions it was something
completely new and we kind of enjoyed
that experience it was really nice it's
really cool to hear that because I mean
again I know that as much as
and to use whatever you've got at a
certain point you're just grabbing for
all the parts of you possible and
putting it out there and it was it was
really clear the music how important
that was and a storyboard is an
anatomatic or essential they can take
you very far but
if you add the music you know since the
beginning to it's it conveys emotion in
a way that a storyboard or an animatic
will never do yeah so that was that was
quite the experience yeah
so on the flying sailor
um you already talked about the
animation and I mean it was so I love
just hearing it because of the effect
that you described of this ballet dance
with this
fat sailor Guy naked I mean it was but
it was lyrical and beautiful
but
can you talk a little bit about how you
use live action as well integrating it
into the film rather than animating it
or you anyway you
you made it feel like part of that world
how did you do that how did you and why
did you make that choice
first started the film we just decided
to
over the storyboard stage and go
straight to animatic so that we just
started feeding the animatic with
whatever we had and so that was some
drawing some stock shots some archival
footage still images You Name It We
chucked it in there just to get the
shape of the thing and also like as well
we like to work with music right from
the beginning we'd not be musicians
tried
I don't know a thousand temp tracks to
try to figure out what exactly was the
tone we wanted for this thing
and so
um
partly doing that we we a couple of the
shots we had in there uh stock shots and
we would just put a drawn sailor over a
live action shot just to give the idea
and one of them was a very beautiful
probably a drone shot that was rising up
over a fire in a city and and and
turning and we thought that's that's
what we want and we had thought that we
were going to animate it in 2D but
thought how are we going to blow down a
whole city maybe Glenn Keane could do
that but I'm not sure that we're ready
for that so we decided to go to 3D for
that and so that was New Territory for
us and then we thought that as the 3D
started coming into Focus
we'd look at these live action shots
like looking out of the porthole out at
the ocean rising and falling we thought
that really works and why would we mess
with that you know just to make a point
there were animators no uh so we decided
to keep them and um
then we knit it all together with a lot
of color adjustment and and Grain and
and a little bit of blur and just to try
to get them all married but
the and then the Sailor the the
characters
as 2D renderings uh that was important
to us because that's fundamentally our
wheelhouse that's we love we love
we love 2D and also that it made him
stand out from his background in a way
that that was important to us and we
also felt that um
we needed to keep that grip on him
because we knew how to
make him work for us with a 3D character
uh we just weren't ready to to take that
on of of trying to make a Sim I don't
know how sympathetic that character is
but um to make him as sympathetic as we
wanted him to be it was safer for us to
keep him in 2D
it worked really well that yeah it did
not jump out it was and it made it feel
like memory it was yeah well thank you
we're relieved to hear that because
there were some uh tense moments earlier
on when because the 3D was brand new to
us and as
probably a lot of you know 3D looks
like crap up until the end you know I
mean it's it or it can do so it can be
um it just as it as it is built it it
can look very cheesy and that was our
main fear and we knew that we had to
work a lot with it in compositing to
make it as we wanted it and and which
was a very low rent thing we weren't
aspiring to do
what Pixar can do or Disney uh you know
we were we were looking at model train
set
um sort of Aesthetics for what we were
doing but still we we just thought okay
if that's if it's if a bit looks bad we
just threw more smoke at it or chunks of
debris or something like that to cover
it but
um but I also just wanted to Echo what
um
um Bruno and joy was saying about just
the importance of Music and Sound
because that was absolutely key for us
and our animatic
um really actually started with sound
and that's uh that's the backbone of
everything for the shape of the the
thing and you know without
the definition that music and sound
provides uh you know the film is really
nowhere and uh so Central was a big
explosion but also the music and the
Transitions and the music
um it almost became like a kind of an
opera or something in its um tonal
changes and that was really fun for us
but we had the pleasure of working with
Luigi alemanos an old friend of ours and
he's an animator as well as a composer
and we worked really closely with him
and um we're very happy with how that
ended up as well
yeah I was just noticing the way every
the music was always preparing you for
what was about to happen by not
necessarily signaling it but setting you
up for the surprise turn that was about
to happen it was really amazing thank
you yeah
so
Charlie looking at your book
looking at the animation
um
I don't know that I've ever seen a book
translated into animation
that is faithfully and it made me think
of
um
my mentors who were always
teaching me to
to observe
from her life and put that into your
your poses and let the poses communicate
and
um
there's a sincerity was what I heard the
sincerity is the key to animation
and can you talk about
for you
how you were able to Faithfully
Translate
there's still drawings into moving
drawings
yeah thank you anyways it was a
difficult job looking at Cara now
um we had a phenomenal team
and I I'm you know I'm an imposterally I
learned that they
car and her team had two jobs one was to
teach me how to make a film the other
one was to make a film and I when I when
I was observing and you know we had the
animatics and all that stuff and I
remember seeing Tim Watts who's an
animator did these pencil drawings of
the horse moving for three seconds I'm
thinking that's the most beautiful thing
I've seen in a long time can't we just
have pencil drawings because it's so
stunning but that was there were so many
stages to make the ink look like the ink
of the book it wasn't just ink straight
away it was you know studying from life
you know live references and then
obviously the ink came after but um
yeah it was it and we all really tried
to make it look like the characters that
walked off the page and into the onto
the screen that was our dream
um
it was successful I mean I didn't think
that you could accomplish that but when
I saw the film's like whoa that was
quite an accomplishment
um can I Matthew can I ask you a
question about
the boy the the mole The Fox and the
horse
um
that why those characters
maybe this is about Charlie but you know
Charlie
um and to share a little bit about that
oh
um but they're all Charlie
um
uh I I and I think they're probably all
aspects of all of us I think I think the
four different
characters make up
you know that the the different sort of
voices and and
um
aspects of of people's personality
I think the original question that you
asked everyone which everyone ignored
was about the the voicing
um and the casting of uh of it and it
that was a really challenging piece for
I think for for our film because
there's so little in the in the book
that defines the characters so I think
one of the reasons why so many people
related to it is because they saw
themselves
in the boy in in the the different
characters and and so when you've got a
a well-loved source material you know
the danger is is that you you
in translating it onto the screen you
you you confound or you conflict with
people's internal understanding that
there was we had a wonderful moment
during lockdown when Oprah Winfrey
picked the boy the molar thoughts and a
horse as a book and and she read it
um in one of her her broadcasts and she
um and and she did voices for each of
the of the four characters and and uh
they were brilliant but they were they
definitely weren't
I think the way that we'd imagined those
voices and and so so in trying to
find a voice for each of the of the four
characters it was a you know trying to
be true to to the the
relatable aspect of of each of them and
Charlie had a I mean he definitely had a
strong sense I think of of how each
character would would
um would speak
the character The Voice has to feel like
it's coming out of the design of a
character and you've designed the
character already now you have to find
the voice that fits that it's such a
clever thing to say yeah
um the boy was always Scottish to me
because I wanted to have his voice to
emulate the landscape and the boy when
he says I'm lost or when the the evolves
along it looks like a wide landscape
um so yeah the voice is really important
and my favorite bit of anything to do
with the voices probably was we were
struggling to find someone to do the
horse and I hand wrote this letter to
Gabriel Byrne got his address and then
because I did Gabriel you don't know if
you did a little book of women doing a
little filming defense here's my number
and uh you know we do that you don't
think anyone's gonna ever ring you back
no one Rings it back anyway let alone
Gabriel Byrne so you know and then I got
a phone call from a foreign to me and I
answered it and the voice said is that
Charlie
and I said yeah he says Gabriel I said
all right Gabriel how are you I said
good thanks did he get he got the letter
then he said I did I said do you did you
so you got did you know the book he said
I have the book I said oh lovely do you
do you fancy you know
doing what being the horse and the Ron
Paul said Charlie I am the horse
and I laid on the cross and cried
because I just thought oh my God that's
unbelievable so yeah it was a great
journey to find you know one of the
characters voices to represent their
physicalities yeah what a great yeah
so
on the ostrich told me the world is fake
and and I think I believe it
um
you've got a character there that
is so uncomfortable in his world and
confused and you've set yourself up
for quite a challenge
to to hang on to that where am I what's
going on this of an animation much less
with with stop-motion
um how how did you keep how did you keep
communicating for the audience that he's
trying to figure out what the heck is
going on here but I I don't know and I'm
feeling uncomfortable how did you how
did you approach that
um I think there's obviously a lot of
myself in there that kind of naturally
helps sell that character I did the
voice I did the
um the reference footage and then
animated it so there's no doubt a lot of
myself in there and I um so so yeah I
think
um that was kind of the important part
of of being able to connect with that
character very quickly and so you kind
of invest in them and then when all this
other stuff happens you kind of you care
for that character and um when we later
see it sort of plopped in the bin is
just this lifeless uh puppet you kind of
go oh you know because you've spent all
that time with them and so I think that
was the kind of place I was trying to
get to
um and and yeah that's why I spent a lot
of time making sure we kind of felt for
him and for his story here the acting
choices that he made were really
wonderful like where he he comes around
and he notices the guy is only half of a
person there you know and
how you you let the audience know how
he's feeling by him not just turning and
walking away but keeping his eyes as
he's backing away I mean making choices
that are like I think you can see him
thinking like yeah he saw this guy she
said
right yeah yeah I love that sort of
stuff and yeah figuring out those
idiosyncrasies that yeah that's help
sell a character
I can see lights flashing and it means
that I've forgotten how much time has
passed
and people are going like mesmerizing
well you find out can I ask the lady who
has a ringtone that says bad sings Bad
Mama Jama did the person make their own
ringtone for you were they like I'm bad
mama jama or were you like
think
well thank you so much for sharing for
your openness I've I've learned a lot
and want to apply it to whatever it is I
do I think that's the real value of
being here together uh is iron sharpens
iron one person sharpens another
creatively and that's what we've been
doing here really and for all of you too
so let's give our panelists hand
thank you
thank you now we sit up here until
somebody tells us to leave
we have we have cast and crew here so if
you have more questions for my your
dicks and all of us I know we all
brought people so if you enjoyed what
you saw find someone and tell them
well I'll be doing that I would love to
say this has been one of my favorite
experiences just hearing everybody here
and everybody's got these such beautiful
stories and I kind of feel maybe every
year the academy when however I don't
know how from they happen the nominee
said we should all kind of um make a
film together
[Laughter]
I mean why not
start now we'll be done in 10 years
[Laughter]
um do we have a question yes
I'm so sorry for you
hi Amanda yeah hello
thank you
oh thank you thank you so much
I do yes
right
absolutely thank you
thank you for saying that so I think
we're going to go ahead and exit off
stage and get together back backstage so
thank you very much
well then Glenn
and King
button that was lovely